bonsoir à toutes et à tous or on vient
pas naturellement à se préoccuper de
questions liées à la monnaie en fait au
départ la base jeunes élus de ce
territoire maire d'une petite commune et
qui dans mes mandats eu à s'occuper à se
préoccuper je pars quand il faut dire de
deux questions liées à la pauvreté
rapidement quand on se pose ces
questions là la monnaie appareil
apparaît comme étant une question mais
je trouve que étant élu il n'y a pas de
formation pour être élu ça c'est un truc
il faut bien avoir présent à l'esprit
mais n'importe qui peut être élu former
ou pas il connaît la monnaie il connaît
pas la monnaie c'est pas le tout si le
tout c'est d'avoir été élu donc là je me
suis dit mais comme pour se préoccuper
vraiment des questions de pauvreté
pour comprendre comment fonctionne la
bonne et je vais aller étudier les
mollets une formation d'ingénieur part
d'économistes donc je me suis dit je
vais lire des livres
quand on est élu on n'a pas le temps
c'est long je me suis je regarde les
émissions de télé des reportages le ça
dure une heure et demi c'est long
alors j'ai trouvé des reportages des
documentaires vachement bien vu qui
passe entre les gros autre grand des
émissions en fait ça dure trente
quarante secondes 20 secondes des fois
c'est vachement bien ses jambes et sa
publicité moi je trouve que c'est les
meilleurs documentaires que l'on fait la
preuve que ce documentaire on apprend
beaucoup de choses
moi quand j'ai commencé à regarder la
question de la monnaie à l'étudier par
le biais de ses documentaires j'ai vu
que j'apprenais des choses première
chose que j'ai apprise puisque j'ai vu
plein de gens différents qui me disaient
mais alors la main sur le coeur que
j'aime ma banque
aussi savoureux vous saviez pas bon moi
je savais pas moi j'aime le chocolat
si vous voulez après je vous dis une
excellente adresse sur toulouse mais la
banque s'est tenu comme ça naturellement
dont je cherchais à comprendre pourquoi
les gens il aimait leurs bagues et je me
suis dis le je vais poser la question à
mes administrés pour voir que 6e parmi
eux il y en a qui aiment leurs banques
donc j'allais voir mes amis inscrits et
qui m'a dit mais moi banques ont
préoccupé pas je vais un kopeck
là je me suis dit mais c'est ça ce qui
lui faut que j'invente c'est le kopeck
il faut que je demande qu'on va lui
donner du kopeck alors tel projet dont
je vous parlais pas souhaité qu'on est
en train de créer jeu c'était
coopérative kopeck je promets que c'est
vrai qui aura vocation à lutter contre
la pauvreté sur ce territoire le
territoire c'est la france entière et je
vais essayer nourrir comment en fait ce
que je me suis dit c'est peu pour lutter
contre la pauvreté j'allais imaginer une
banque une monnaie qui soit différente
donc ce que j'ai fait je viens mon coin
et je rêve d'une banque
mais là tout d'un coup je me suis dit ça
c'est déjà fait en fait
et puis alors cette banque que là on
prie on l'a retrouvée au panama je me
suis dit si je rêve une banque comme ça
ça va être compliqué donc je me suis dit
on imaginer une manière de fonctionner
différemment les plutôt que de rêver et
de faire rêver
j'ai regardé tout ce que je ne
comprenais pas dans la banque dans la
mort 1
tout est compliqué dans la banque dans
la monnaie c'est le temps ça le lien
qu'il ya entre le temps et la baule est
vraiment important de comprendre ça
en fait coluche l économiste et bilan a
dit à un moment donné les gens veut
enfin on dit qu'il faut donner du
travail aux gens alors que simplement un
peu d'argent j'irai et je crois que
c'est vrai et d'ailleurs la preuve que
c'est vrai quand on a beaucoup d'argent
plutôt que travailler on fait travailler
argent c'est nettement moins pénible et
pour ça pour l'allier c'est le temps
avec le temps on fait des dates de
valeur avec le temps on fait de
l'intérêt est en fête avec ça on ne sut
- ont fait suer l'argent mais ce qui se
passe c'est que c'est terriblement
terriblement mal distribuer les dons via
un tout petit nombre qui possède
énormément de cet argent là et du temps
de cet argent et en grand nombre qui
regarde juste passé l'argent en fait ce
qui se passe c'est que quand il y en a
400 euros 100 yens 100 dollars dans la
nature il ya 98 qui sert en fait
retournés en chine financière et 2 pour
la prochain en fait c'est 98 % parce
qu'il attire qu'on regarde juste
travailler sans que nous travaillions
pour nous travaillez souvent contre nous
et donc il faut essayer de la pensée
différent dans le complexe a aucun
rapport au temps d'ailleurs j'ai une
petite particularité
je suis maire depuis de communes et sur
ma commune n'y a pas de cimetière
vachement important de la formation du
maire que je suis donc meilleures bandes
cimetière je me suis fondu prennent des
arrêtés pour interdire mourir comme ça
c'est vachement triste mourir je sais
pas si vous avez vu ça des familles
c'est vrai c'est un souci rapport au
temps et l'argent c'est pas la même
chose en fait ce qui se passe c'est que
ceux qui ont de l'argent qui font voulu
prêter vont essayer de regagner de
l'argent afin que vous ayez disparu
c'est très important
d'où l'intérêt les assurances excuses
assurant sans qu'on la même gestion du
temps et de l'argent et donc le kopeck
n'aura aucun rapport au temps le pas
vous dire que ça va vous rendre immortel
nombreux faut pas faire des promesses
dès que je fais de la politique loin
faut pas faire des promesses
inconsidérées le cop est gras par un
immortel va pas régler tous les
problèmes du monde mais avec le kopeck
il y aura pas de dates de valeur savez
ce temps entre le moment où c'est que
vous pensez donner de l'argent à
quelqu'un et où l'autre pense le
recevoir il ya un délai est entre les
deux mais quelqu'un qui a de l'argent
avec votre argent 0 délais y a pas
d'intérêt
pas d'intérêt le kopeck des pressions
possibles seront à 0% pas de placement
alors certes ya pas de livret a mais ya
pas de commissions non plus quand vous
allez chez un commerçant vous ne payez
pas de commission ni vous entends
clients ni l'autre interlocuteur en tant
que vendeur le pire c'est que je me suis
trouvé géniale peut être un moment donné
et puis j'ai vu que j'existe depuis 80
ans en suisse où il ya une monnaie
complémentaire qui fonctionne à peu près
comme ça depuis 1934
le veer et ça représente 2% du produit
intérieur brut de la suisse
là je me suis trouvé de terriblement
idiot j'avais qu'à aller faire du ski en
suisse
là j'aurai pas eu à rêver une banque
puisque c'était déjà fait en fait la
manière dont on va la mettre en place
c'est d'essayer de mettre en place
entièrement numérique le mollet va
fonctionner au 1er octobre prochain
cette monnaie qu'il aura pas de
commission qui n'aura pas d'intérêt
qu'il n'aura pas de valeur va
fonctionner uniquement sous forme
coopérative tous les gens qui vont
vouloir utiliser des entreprises des
particuliers ont juste une colonisation
dans l'abonnement à la mener pour
participer de ce système et le business
plan de ce projet consiste à faire en
sorte que avec le seul abonnement 20
euros pour un particulier 50 euros pour
une entreprise on arrive à faire
fonctionner sa et à partir de là on a
commencé à rêver un peu là bang et
regarder tout ce qui fonctionne et
bizarrement ou qui était décevant
dans la rue alsace lorraine vous avez
distributeurs de billets je n'ai pas
remarqué à quel point c'est décevant
mais seraient victorieux face et si
c'était ça vous allez chercher 100 euros
qu'est ce qui vous arrive et 100 euros
alors que 105 serait tellement mieux
alors là on va vous donner 5 vous allez
paris avec 100 euros
on voudrait 105 avec 6,6 et un kopeck
vaut 1 euro parce que dans les autre
manière de gérer le temps c'est un
mollet là ne sera pas de mon les
spéculations sera à parité avec l'euro
mais on va vous en aurez sec de plus ça
fait que vous allez avant voire l'achat
de 5 % + 5 % j'envoie glisse le bon goût
on veut redonner cinq de plus en fait
avec 100 euros ou wav données 105 du 5
mai les cinq qui suivent jeudi a pas de
raison qu'on garde toujours les mêmes
donc les 5 on va vous dire voilà sont à
vous mais pas pour vous donc vous allez
les donner à des projets d'intérêt
collectif que on va vous proposer
et si projet là ils ont vocation à
répondre à quatre préoccupations
1 ils doivent permettre la transition
énergétique c'est à dire que les cinq
kopecks supplémentaires que vous allez
avoir vous allez pouvoir donner centrale
photovoltaïque un barrage que sais-je ou
à la transition carbone ce à dire que
vous allez stocker du carbone faire
stocker du carbone dans des projets bien
déterminée ou à la transition
alimentaire financer une ferme bio
financent et de l'agroforesterie ou
enfin participer à la transition sociale
financé des chantiers d'insertion bref
le complexe et surtout la monnaie de la
transition pour faire en sorte que
chaque fois que vous allez acheter un
kopeck
chaque fois que vous allez participer à
l'économie réelle chaque fois vous allez
financer une dca transition la
transition énergétique de transition
alimentaire la transition carbone ou la
tradition sociale c'est ça l'enjeu de la
monnaie
elle démarre je vous le disais tout à
l'heure le 1er octobre les enjeux sont
les suivants en expérimentation ce qu'on
souhaite c'est pas peuvent suivre dans
l'absolu
faire comme les suisses visé à faire 2%
du produit intérieur brut de la suisse
aujourd'hui le franchir c'est un volet
complémentaire suisse à équivalent du
franc suisse
complémentarité de francs suisses 2
milliards de francs vivre sont en
circulation
une entreprise sur cinq du pays si vous
allez faire du ski d'aller voir le fait
du ski l'après-midi le matin allée dans
la vallée dans les vallées industrielle
de la suisse pratiquement toutes les
industries
on compte en france vire qui est une
monnaie privée coopérative également et
si vous allez le soir dans la station
d'aller voir que si vous voulez payer en
francs de vire vous pouvez payer votre
restaurant brandir de la même façon pour
nous les objectifs sont les suivants fin
2018 ce qu'on voudrait c'est avoir mis
en circulation 10 millions d'équivalent
euros
la création monétaire liée à ce temps
génère un produit intérieur brut
supplémentaires on n'espère les secondes
et on met en place un comité
scientifique qui aura vocation à
surveiller sans que ces 10 millions
d'euros mis en circulation auront généré
de l'ordre 2040 complet et on a découpé
tout le territoire national en 300 rue
secteur est aujourd'hui ces jours ci
nous sommes en train de démarrer le
recrutement de ceux qui vont être nos
distributeurs nos active est inventé au
monde de plus pour dire ce qu'ils vont
faire la promotion de la monnaie sur les
territoires et de faire en sorte de
faire mentir l'adage que ça vaut pas un
kopeck
ça va valoir beaucoup plus sur un kopeck
je vous remercie